we live in an age where we have
unprecedented access to information
studies and research on the web this in
turn might lead you to assume that we
would be better educated and wiser than
ever before unfortunately though it
doesn't take much research before you
realize that a lot of this information
is contradictory and it seems that every
few years everything we know about
nutrition is turned on its head fats are
bad for us then they're good for us then
HDL cholesterol is good for us but LDL
isn't then all cholesterol is good for
us how can you know what to trust before
you get too disheartened know that these
constant paradigm shifts are actually an
example of good science the objective of
any scientific study or research should
be to try and disprove not prove a
theory theories that can't be disproved
of what we call unfalsifiable that's not
to say that they're incorrect but simply
that they aren't scientific as they
can't be subjected to rigorous testing
[ __ ] that all science is doing testing
theories testing that things work when
someone says that they don't trust
science what they're really saying is
that they don't trust testing things and
to me that's foolishness especially when
it comes to our health by trying to
constantly disprove theories and upset
the status quo scientists are able to
remain unbiased and objective not only
that but it's generally impossible to
prove with absolute certainty that
something is true the unfortunate
by-product of all this though is that
what has held to be the best advice one
year might not be what is considered the
best advice the next year and this is
especially problematic when the official
guidelines provided by health
organizations and governments are not
updated in a timely manner to reflect
our new discoveries it's also a problem
when a company jumps to early
conclusions regarding preliminary week
results and thus tries to sell us on
snake oil products does this mean you
can't trust any research because it's
only going to change somewhere down the
line not really
while our precise understanding may
change over time this doesn't generally
change the practical advice so
frequently or so drastically think of
quantum physics discovery of quantum
mechanics shows that classical Newtonian
physics don't work at a subatomic scale
but that doesn't mean that an apple
won't still fall to the floor when you
drop it
health is similar for the most part
this is also why it's important later do
your own research and to draw your own
conclusions apply a little common sense
try out different ideas and stick with
what works and of course learning to
properly assess the validity of
different studies is also very important
when two studies disagree is usually
because one of those studies has been
carried out poorly let's see how you can
identify that for yourself statistical
significance as mentioned no study can
say with absolute certainty that
anything is true it can only refute
existing theories one reason for this is
there's always the element of chance so
let's say I've got a supplement called
ultra strong supplement and I want to
find out if it works or not
before I start selling it so I give it
to five participants and I look at their
strengths before they start taking the
supplement and afterwards if those five
participants all got stronger noticeably
then I might conclude that my supplement
ultra strong supplement was effective
however there's actually a very good
chance that that was just a complete
flip perhaps those five people were just
recovering from colds and so at the end
of the study they were stronger than
they were at the start or perhaps they
were just hitting their stride at the
gym or maybe some other factor led to
them getting stronger I can't prove that
that wasn't just a coincidence and
that's why you need a much larger sample
the larger the sample the less likely it
is that it was just a coincidence so if
I had a hundred participants and ninety
nine of them got stronger moving ultra
strong supplement then I might conclude
that it's highly likely that they did
get stronger because of this supplement
the studies are forced to deal with the
significance of data this basically
tells you how likely it is statistically
for the results to have been caused by
what you were testing this is measured
with the p-value where P equals naught
point naught four would mean that there
was a four percent likelihood that your
results were a fluke generally it's
considered that a significant result is
five percent or below only then can
research a claim that they found some
kind of real-world relationship and
reject their null hypothesis the
prediction that nothing of note will
happen what this tells you though is
that when
see a big study published in the news
they're still possibly a 5 percent
chance that it was just luck don't read
the hyperbolic Daily Mail headlines then
go straight to the source of the study
and find out what the statistical
significance really was then you're
probably safe to assume that the results
were at least not just chance samples
but we also need to think about the
nature of those participants if all of
those participants were people who
regularly went to the gym anyways then
it might not have actually been the case
that this supplement works for everyone
it may have only worked for people who
had experience in the gym already
therefore we need to get a more
representative sample in that case we
might get a stratified sample and that
means that the sample is designed to be
reflective of the general public it
means we've got roughly the right number
of men and women roughly the right
number of different races different ages
different demographics many studies we
use something called opportunity
sampling meaning they get participants
wherever they can often these
participants will be found at
universities because this is where a lot
of research is carried out that means
that the participants might well be
students at the very least it means
they're all the kind of person who are
willing to participate in studies thus
you should check to see if the sample is
an opportunity sample a quota sample
designed to include representatives from
different demographics a random sample
or a stratified sample designed to be a
mini reproduction of the actual
population many studies use random
samples which generally should be
representative if the sample is large
enough confounding variables so if a
study uses a huge sample that is
completely random and likely
representative of the general population
and their findings are highly
significant can you trust it not
necessarily if a study is badly designed
that it can still have misleading
results even when they are significant
for instance if I were to give my cure
for the flu to a million people that I
knew were currently getting better then
I would have a highly significant result
that nevertheless wasn't worth anything
it's unusual for anyone to say
flagrantly attempt to play the system
though more likely is that they simply
fail to account for the fact that
everyone had been ill for roughly the
same amount of time and was showing
signs of improvement this is what's
known as a confounding variable maybe
you got your participants to swallow
down any
with milk and perhaps it was actually
the milk that gave him the results so a
confounding variable is anything else
that could have affected the study so in
the case of our super strong supplement
that could be the fact that we gave the
super strong supplement to people then
we introduced a new workout routine at
the same time there'll be a very bad
design and that would be an example of a
confounding variable now of course in
observational studies where we're not
actually interfering where we're not
carrying the study out in a lab
confounding variables are much more
common because they can't control for
every factor so we might look at people
who eat lots of hot dogs and we might
notice that they gain weight we spot
that correlation however we haven't
considered all the other factors for
instance someone who eats hot dogs is
also much more like to eat Mars bars is
much more likely to exercise less these
are confounding variables and unless we
control for them by for instance forcing
people who don't eat hot dogs to eat all
the other junk food and to not exercise
then we can't say with certainty that
the hot dogs caused the obesity we can
only say there's a correlation and
that's one of the trials that's one of
the issues when we use any kind of
observational study first you can say
that in a real-world setting
eating more hot dogs correlates with
worse health that is to say that someone
who eats more hot dogs is likely to have
poorer health what you cannot say though
is that the hot dogs were what caused
the bad health this doesn't only apply
to observational studies either thus a
good study should do everything it can
to eliminate or account for confounding
variables our study looking at diet for
instance should control precisely what's
being eaten make sure that the
participants are getting similar amounts
of exercise and generally avoid anything
that might influence the outcome of the
study normally this means creating a
control group that means you're
splitting the sample in half and only
intervening with one of the two groups
so you might give one group your
experimental treatment and the other one
no experimental treatment the idea of
this is to create a group that you can
compare the results to where the only
difference is the new medicine or
whatever variable you're testing so
maybe different participants have
different diets but this shouldn't be
true in both groups thus by comparing
the two groups and seeing if the
difference is significant you can get an
idea as to whether your intervention had
any effect
while researchers should know better
they will often still jump to
conclusions and claim that a causal link
was found when really
they've only shown a correlation is the
study you're reading guilty of that the
placebo effect
one of the biggest confounding variables
that researchers have to contend with in
research is the perceiver effect the
placebo effect is what happens when a
participant feels differently because
they believe they will be give someone a
new drug to treat their flu and they'll
be optimistic that they're going to get
better that alone can then improve their
immune system and the result will be a
faster recovery solution then is to use
a blind study meaning the control group
will receive a sugar pill and the
experimental group will get the real
treatment only they don't know which one
they're getting thus the placebo should
affect both groups equally so any
difference can be considered the result
of the active ingredients or the
lifestyle changes or whatever it is
you're testing so in a double-blind
experiment the researchers don't know
which of the groups is the experimental
group in which is the control group and
neither of course do the subjects this
is so that the researchers can't
accidentally introduce any kind of bias
through their knowledge of the
experiment for instance it might be that
the experimenter goes to the
experimental group and says so have you
noticed any benefits yet and then they
go to the control group when they go so
notice any benefits yet probs not and
that subtle difference could influence
the way that the participants view the
experiment and therefore we might see
the placebo effects being stronger in
the experimental group than in the
control group so if neither party if
nobody knows who's the experimental
group and who's the control group then
there's no chance of that happening long
attitudinal studies you also need to
consider the length of the study how
long was this new diet and exercise
regime trial before it was concluded
that it worked or didn't work sometimes
a new diet can cause positive effects in
the short-term like weight loss but very
negative effects in the long-term like
death if you were to study the starve
yourself diet for two days you'd
probably say it was very effective
longitudinal studies then are very
useful as they monitor their
participants over very long periods of
time sometimes their entire lifetimes
of course these studies are also largely
impractical however so they are fewer
and further in between another problem
with the longitudinal studies is that
they can't take place in the lab meaning
you can't control for many variables
resulting in correlations rather than
causation animal studies many health
studies are conducted on animals due to
those pesky ethical issues surrounding
the use of human test subjects
unfortunately we're not allowed to test
the genetic engineering or obscure new
drugs on humans so we have to use
animals instead normally rats or mice
well this will usually be fine due to
the similarities in their biology it's
not the most representative sample in
the world one of the biggest differences
of course being size although it's not
quite that clear-cut because it does
appear that the smaller the animal the
larger the relative dose is required to
trigger an effect foul play finally it's
worth noting that it's very easy to
manipulate data and design studies to
pull the wool over someone's eyes so
it's always important to look at who
funded any study because there might be
alterior motives which could
intentionally or unintentionally have
skewed the results so for instance you
might have heard of type A and type B
personality theory they type A
personality as they go getta is the
competitive type the driven type type B
is much more Placid relaxed turns out
that this personality theory is based on
nothing it's based on research done by
funded by the cigarette industry in
order to try and prove that cigarettes
weren't and healthy the idea being they
wanted to show that type A personalities
were more likely to have heart attacks
and strokes and hypertension and they
also wanted to show that type A
personalities were more likely to smoke
and that way they could say that the
link between smoking and heart attacks
wasn't anything to do with the actual
cigarettes causing the heart attacks but
rather there was the confounding
variable that being the fact that those
people were more driven that's not to
say that type A personality in type B
plus Snuffy don't exist or that we don't
have competitive and non-competitive
people it's very likely that we do
however that study was done for the
wrong reasons and we now quote this
theory as though it was just as valid as
any other personality theory when
actually there was a very set objective
for looking into it sometimes of course
there can be some real foul play going
on
where they might ease the median instead
of the mode because it paints a better
picture or they might even completely
remove outliers from their study say
this person was too extreme in order to
completely change the average or to make
the study significant when it wouldn't
have been otherwise again you've just
got to use your own critical thinking do
some reading and ideally look for more
than one piece of research that backs up
the same point
that is something I'd like to emphasize
is just because something is funded by a
certain group that doesn't mean that the
study wasn't carried out correctly
actually almost all research is funded
by somebody and of course that's
normally gonna be a party that has an
interest in the outcome as long as the
study was carried out correctly then it
shouldn't matter who funded it and
that's why you need to use a critical
eye do you trust the researchers and
looking at the methods they used is
there any way this could have been
skewed and for those things in that
natural supplements are better because
they aren't funded by Big Pharma just
remember that those homeopathic remedies
here have been shown countless times not
to work are still making a ton of money
themselves if pharmaceutical companies
just wanted to make money don't you
think they'd be selling those as well
yes research can sometimes be confusing
cynical and difficult to understand but
don't use this as an excuse to stop
researching and put your faith in some
magic plant that no one is willing to
test
while there are many more factors to
consider when assessing a health study
this post will hopefully have given you
enough information to start getting a
better idea of what works and what
doesn't the question is what do you do
with all that information so that we
found this video useful and interesting
guys if you did then please leave likely
[ __ ] around that helps me out immensely
let me know in the comments down below
if I missed anything I'd love to know
your thoughts I've got a whole lot more
like this on the way if that sounds good
then thanks a ton for watching and I'll
see you next time bye for now